it is something of a desperate landmark
moment the UK getting beyond 29,000
deaths and as you probably heard
overtaking Italy to become to have the
biggest death toll in Europe it's worth
asking the question whether these
comparisons are actually of any use and
I'm not entirely sure that they are not
in that sense right you'll remember this
chart there was one sense it's were one
way and which is worth just looking at
how different countries have been
evolving and that is to get a sense of
where you're heading so we did look at
this chart and looked at trajectories
and looked at how the UK was tracking
Italy for a while and it gave us a sense
of where we might be heading but as for
the absolute numbers well let's have a
look at where they are at the moment you
can see there the UK now 29,000 427
deaths compared with Italy 29,000 315
deaths clearly the UK higher there and
if you look at it in bull terms just
taking those numbers and putting them
into kind of a bar chart you can see
pretty clearly the u.s. there with by
far away the most deaths from covert 90
in the UK and then Italy and then Spain
France and Belgium on this quite a long
way down but it's worth bearing in mind
you probably could have spotted the the
kind of thing here which is that the US
has a large population far larger than
most of these other countries the UK has
a bigger population than Italy so what
would be slightly better actually is to
take this chart and adjust it so that
each of these lines are adjusted for
population I can do that for you now and
it's a subtly different picture here
Belgium which was quite low down has
suddenly gone up towards the top and
Spain is still up there actually Spain's
above the UK Italy's above the UK
Ireland is actually quite close to the
UK and Ireland is above the US and so
when you just take those numbers and
adjust them for population which is one
way of looking at this you get a very
different picture it is still very bad
indeed for the UK and for many other
countries but it is not quite the same
picture as you might have seen from
those overall numbers the UK there below
Italy below Spain and actually the
country with the most severe covered 19
outbreak as in population adjusted terms
this is Belgium look at bottom over
there 694 deaths per million of the
population and what this underlines is
that there are so many different ways of
measuring this I'm not saying anyone is
the definitive but just bear that in
mind when you hear these scary numbers
I'll give you
there's three three key measures we're
gonna bear in mind that the first of
them you'll have heard a lot and this is
the one we're talking about at the
moment which is the numbers that the
government give us every day on how many
people have died of covet 19 you can see
a few a week and a half ago it was up to
twenty-two thousand according to what we
got from the government each day but
that's not everything we also get more
coherent more comprehensive numbers from
the ons which include everyone who's
died of covert 19 or at least who has
Coppa 19 on their death certificate and
their numbers show actually at that
point it was higher so not twenty two
thousand but twenty-six thousand but
according to the chief scientific
adviser there is a different way
different kind of number we should be
looking at which is not just covert
nineteen diagnose deaths but all excess
deaths all excess deaths which are
considerably higher and I'm going to
show you why that matters if we look at
what's happened in the care home sector
this line here shows you how many people
died each week of the year just over the
course of the last few years so the
average number of people who died in in
care homes over the year and what we do
if we look at just where we are this
years so far you can see excess deaths
so the number of people who have died
above that line have risen to 16,000 in
total over that period that's a high
number but here's what's intriguing if
we break that down look at this 6,000
only 6,000 of those deaths are notified
as covert 19 deaths that means there's
an extra 10,000 excess deaths that
simply aren't explained by those numbers
that we get every day that's pretty
striking and that's why excess deaths is
probably the best measure of what's
going on you know we don't know
precisely why these people have died but
it's so far above the average one would
assume it's associated with either the
lock down or indeed just undiagnosed
covert 19 and it's the same picture
across the UK not quite as marked and
but this shows you all deaths across
England and Wales and it's a similar
picture to say in Scotland or Northern
Ireland excess deaths since March 38,000
let's break that down and you can see
27,000 of them were diagnosed as covert
19 or on the certificate eleven thousand
one so you've got an extra 11 thousand
deaths across the UK that simply haven't
been explained above the average now we
need to focus on excess death to get the
most comprehensive measure of what's
going on
in the UK and indeed other countries and
I should say other countries because
remember when we're talking about
whether the UK has overtaken Italy as
some people seem fixated on the question
is what measure and we know for instance
from this measure that the UK's
undercounting excess deaths in those
daily numbers we get by that forty
percent so the daily numbers are about
forty percent below where the eventual
excess deaths may turn out to be and if
we compare just one points where each
country got beyond eleven thousand
deaths this is again those official
daily numbers that we have on the 31st
of March Italy went beyond eleven
thousand deaths on the 10th of April the
UK went at the same point what we now
know is that at that point actually
those weren't the full death tolls there
were a lot more excess deaths on top of
that so in the UK there were four
thousand XS that just weren't counted by
those daily tolls that we've got but
here's the striking thing look at Italy
we now know there were thirteen point
seven thousand thirteen thousand seven
hundred deaths that just weren't counted
in those official numbers so whereas the
UK is under Counting excess deaths at
that point by 38 percent Italy was under
counting them by well kind of it was
double the actual total of death toll
that we got each day what that
underlines is when we're looking at
these numbers when we're looking at
death tolls there are so many different
ways of measuring it and while the
overall number at the moment may say
that the UK has overtaken Italy to have
the biggest death toll in Europe
actually the definitive numbers excess
deaths may not show them unfortunately
though it'll be a while until we get
these numbers